laughing la the Chi Ponzi is just one
and a half her mother was killed by
hunters and souls as push met a man
recently came to the Liberian Chi pansy
risky and protection center wanting to
sell Ella as a pet a stuffed member
recorded the conversation the seller
doesn't seem to understand but baby chip
and Z's wouldn't survive alone in the
wild in the bush chimpanzees live with
their mothers until they're five years
old Jenna Briggs has become a foster
parent she looked after Ella for the
next four years Ella is lucky to have
such a devoted camera I really like to
be with him
I love them so much I wish that if they
can find place for them in the future
it can find be pleased when you grow or
you put in there and they were they
paying people to pay also feed them
because the deputy yes Ally they would
receive if you were an abusive Ella's
been fed now it's time for grooming and
playing the love Toby groom a gumiho in
a few months
Ella will go to the big outdoor
enclosure to play with a bigger
chimpanzees there are 24 there with so
many mouths to feed
it's a non-stop job for the team of 15
workers caring for one chip on Z cost
around $4,000 a year it's important the
staff know how to treat them they're
wild animals after all yeah you know
pets you can't keep them in the house
because they'll scatter everything
they're friendly but sometimes as soon
as they reach certain age sometimes
they'll come and take your food and put
it in their mouths
the chimpanzee population has been in
decline for decades during the two civil
wars they were a sought-after source of
meat one left vet Jim Desmond and his
wife Jenny have been running the
sentences 2015 today caring for the
young animals keeps the team busy
so far the Desmond's have funded the
initiative mainly out of their own
pockets they haven't had the means to
integrate the animals into wild but now
the organization has found and purchased
suitable land and they plan to set up a
protected area of 50 square kilometers
on a river island not far from the
capital Monrovia it's gonna be great
because it's gonna be a natural
environment for them to learn how to
climb there's certainly some foods that
they'll be able to eat but they'll learn
about living in the wild and then if we
ever do a reintroduction program we
probably have to have a secondary site
where we then teach them you know about
the force that they would be living in
but really it's just going to be great
for them it's just a much more natural
environment than the current environment
that they're living in
Jim hopes to release the fast japansese
into forests next year and hopefully in
a few years
little Ella will get to monkey around
back in a natural habitat